picture postcard perfection
tourists are back in venice but they
won't be arriving anytime
soon on large cruise ships
it follows years of debate about banning
mega cruise ships to protect
venice's lagoon ecosystem
that debate became much more heated with
the arrival in june
of a towering 90 000 ton ship
the government finally announced the ban
in july
after threats from unesco to place
venice a world heritage site on its
endangered list
italy is promising to cover lost wages
for thousands of workers who rely on the
cruise industry to keep them afloat
we hope the government comes up with a
way for us to continue a subsidy might
last a year or two but this decree says
ships won't pass through anymore we need
certainty for our future
this is the judeka canal which cuts
right through the heart
of venice passing by saint mark's square
and it's this very artery through which
these huge ships will no longer be able
to pass
but that doesn't mean they'll be
completely blocked from the venetian
lagoon
the plan is to have large cruise ships
enter the lagoon through a back
channel and dock at the mainland
industrial port of marguera
the problem is the port isn't ready to
receive cruise passengers
city councilor marco gasparinetti grew
up along venice's canals
he welcomes the band but sees it as a
distraction
there's a visible part of the iceberg
the visible tita is the big ships but
with many other problems and the big
ships are not the only one
and what are those problems the fact
that the city is dying
in terms of being leaving a place with
citizens
living inside and not having to commute
to get a job which cannot
give you the chance to live in the city
where you're just a commuter
maeve cuchol is part of an organization
that lobbied for the ban
she sees it as part of a larger push to
focus on long-term sustainability
all of that would be done not to to
shift the focus away from
accommodating tourism to um really
fulfilling the needs of the local
residents who
depend also on the biodiversity of the
lagoon and on the
well-being of the whole environment here
venice rose is a commercial powerhouse
centuries ago to the great benefit of
its people
finding a balance that keeps coffers
full and residents from fleeing
will take more than banning cruise ships
from its waters
adam rainey al jazeera venice
unesco often adds locations to its
endangered list to draw global attention
romania's russia montana mining
landscape was made a world heritage site
last week
but it was also added to the danger list
that's because of threats to resume
mining operations in the area
in 2019 islands and protected areas in
the gulf of california were determined
to be
in danger that's largely because of the
vulnerable situation of an endangered
porpoise
made worse by illegal fishing practices
while
kenya's lake turkana national parks were
added to the danger list in 2018
after reported effects from madame in
neighboring ethiopia
well assad raymond is a spokesman for
the cop 26 coalition which advocates for
climate action
and he's joining us from london it's
good to have you with us and al jazeera
sir thank you very much indeed
let's just talk about the situation in
venice first of all why were these
ships so apparently so damaging
to the ecosystem in venice well
as your piece showed these cruise ships
are often the size of small cities
some carry over seven thousand
passengers they dump huge amounts of
sewage and other
waste into our waters they destroy
valuable marine ecology
they pollute the seas lagoons beaches
and
this industry the cruise ship industry
has literally gone unchecked
they're building bigger and bigger ships
with more and more passengers
producing more and more environmental
impacts including
the two world heritage cities such as
venice where they've damaged homes and
businesses
and of course have helped cause the
flooding that threatens that city
ultimately their only goal is profit
margins while making others pay the
price
for this pollution we often talk about
um air travel as being one of the
primary uh
emitters if you like or one of the
primary impacts on climate change
do you think the shipping around the
world is actually overlooked because
this in many ways is a
story that to those of us outside that
appears to be isolated predominantly to
to venice and and to italy but how
widespread is it
well it's very widespread so let's you
know if we think about just this last
one week
you know the floods the famines the
extreme weather impacts that we've seen
cause havoc all around the world
that's not just another warning that the
climate crisis not something that will
happen in years to come
it's a warning that it's already here
and it's deadly for many so to stop
runaway climate change and the billions
of lives and livelihoods are going to be
infected
requires few changes in this decade so
that's includes
stopping polluting industries and that's
not just fossil fuels or aviation
it's also the shipping industry look one
person on one of those cruise ships
is responsible in just one week for
producing as much emissions
as someone living in africa does over a
whole year
so you know tackling the shipping
industry tracking uh
the cruise ship industry tackling
aviation tackling fossil fuels
we fixing our food system we need to do
all of these things
because that's the scale of the
challenge that is in front of us
and unfortunately despite all of the
alarm bells we've had
lots of hot air from governments empty
promises but they aren't serious about
cutting their emissions and the
emissions that they need to cut
what matters is what we do in the next
10 years and they aren't putting in
place
policies so that people relying on those
industries exactly like the
peace the the person you had on your
piece relying on those industries for
work can be transitioned to new jobs
and they're not financing the measures
that are needed to help especially the
poorest to adapt to these crises one
stark figure that we should remember
just in this last year of the corvid
recovery
rich governments have spent something
close to 16 trillion on the corvette
recovery
but less than two percent of that has
gone to low carbon
economy measures much of it has gone to
barely night the same polluting
companies
that are causing this crisis that
continue to pollute so we really need to
have
um a real shift and a change from the
sort of economic
model and the one that says profit comes
before sustainability and becomes big
for
people in our environment this ruling
does
ban ships these large ships from the
venice lagoon but as adam was just
telling us in his report they're
basically being just redirected to
another part
of the city so everything that you've
talked about all the
the levels of emissions that these ships
are are putting out
still exist is this actually as much of
a victory as environmentalists have been
fighting for this
would have us believe well
i think with all of these challenges we
you've often it's a david and goliath
situation who have local communities
local people fighting decades-long
struggles to raise
issues and see these as the first step
so
of course this doesn't solve the real
problem of course it doesn't go far
enough
it's a first step and i think many
people would see it as as
literally only the first step really the
solution is going to be to ask ourselves
in this world that we live in now can we
afford
to have these mega cruise ships where
people
are sailing around the world causing
huge environmental impacts and damages
can we afford to have these polluting
industries continuing the way that they
are
and frankly the answer is no so
accommodating them
as venice has done to try and build a
new harbor that's just shifting the
problem
and kicking the the the ball down in
into the grasp
it's not really grasping with the real
issue that we all face which is
how do you reduce emissions how do you
switch away from these polluting
industries
how do we create a safer and cleaner and
fairer world for everybody
good to get your thoughts on this assad
rahman we appreciate your time so thank
you very much indeed
always a pleasure thank you